[Music]
the main characteristic of someone who
is a narcissist is lack of empathy you
could have someone who's grandiose and
self-absorbed but they still have a
level of empathy but a narcissist has no
empathy for anyone they don't care about
how other people feel they are not able
to sympathize with the feelings of other
people
[Music]
so I just want to start out by asking
you all have you all ever
encountered a narcissist yes
yes multiple times multiple times wow I
think I have
yes and I'm pretty sure I have I don't
think I have okay you want to share not
that you know it not that I know of I
mean there's a difference between
someone who's self-centered and like a
full-on narcissist right right there are
gradations and we'll kind of walk
through that but anybody want to share
you want to share some of your
experiences that you had a boss
generally they're not worth sharing
they're not worth sharing okay I mean
someone who is completely grandiose I
mean we know that someone who is
completely self-absorbed but the the
main characteristic of someone who is a
narcissist is lack of empathy you could
have someone who's grandiose and
self-absorbed but they still have a
level of empathy but a narcissist has no
empathy for anyone they don't care about
how other people feel they are not able
to sympathize with the feelings of other
people so that's the main characteristic
if you don't see that
um and it's not kind of pervasive then
you're probably not dealing with someone
who's a narcissist you're probably just
dealing with someone who has
narcissistic treats so you use two words
you see is both sympathy and empathy and
prep me from wrong sympathy is when you
feel sorry for someone empathy is when
you can resonate with what someone else
is feeling like usually you have at the
same kind of past that they're dealing
with right now because I could have
sympathy but no empathy because I I
don't know what it feels like to almost
drop or something like that but I feel
sorry for someone who did so well I
would think that as narcissists they
have a lack of empathy I think it goes
kind of both ways in order to be able to
feel the feelings of others you don't
necessarily have to have been have had
experiences their situation right I mean
I would think it'd be both
well
let's look it up yeah I think most
people in Hollywood maybe are
narcissistic yeah no I mean because you
have to be I mean we're talking about
we're talking about media here so I I
mean I would think that most people who
are going into that field they're
trained media has has a way of making it
so that's what it is you're you're kind
of geared to go yeah so so here's what I
would say something like that like let's
just say 50 Shades of Gray like these
people are putting out awful things that
seem like it would be damaging to
anybody that's experiencing that and
then making it cool right like if you
don't care about if people are really
truly experiencing that I mean that
that's that that's sick you know yeah
but see that's the whole thing with
narcissism and why it's so um
why it's so under the radar is because
it's kind of normalized in society and
looked at as a positive you know you've
got a strong character right you have
these reality shows that are out that
are glorifying negativity mean
spiritedness uh self-absorption you have
the stars that are going out and buying
20 30 cars and these are all you know
very much glorified in media so it's
it's looked up upon instead of looked
being looked down upon I mean then you
have social media where you know taking
selfies fuels this kind of thing
probably right I wonder too is it can it
be a learned behavior I mean as you kind
of look at like social media you brought
up it it is very much so self-centered
are we creating more narcissists in in
our world than probably what if men well
you can be of course
um there's nature versus nurture right
so there's those who are kind of brought
up based on societal societal
societal values and things of that sort
and things that they're following in
society and then you also have the
parental upbringing but you also have I
think that you can be born uh with
narcissistic trees
um and I believe that because
um things get passed down generationally
and so depending on where your parents
come came from if your parents were
abused if your parents experienced
trauma how they reacted and responded to
that they could pass down traits to you
so I think that some of it can all can
be passed down but then also most of it
is learned you know when you're
um how how you experienced your parents
love how they met your needs how they um
a modeled behavior for you character for
you that all has to do with what you'll
emulate and the types of relationships
that you'll have as you get older
so would you say someone like in history
like Hitler was a narcissist well
definitely yeah definitely he was a
malignant narcissist so there are five
types of narcissists there's the classic
narcissist that's a narcissist that's
just your your age-old grandiose just
self-absorbed uh lacks empathy
narcissist you know then there's the
malignant narcissist this is the person
who is grandiose they have all the
traits of a classic narcissist but they
are mean-spirited so they they want to
hurt you uh they have no care for their
victim
uh they they they are just they're evil
then we also have the covert narcissist
um those are the people who are more
under the radar more role is me that
they kind of have more of a um tie with
depression so the covert narcissist you
would think that they're more depressed
because he the world just is just not
doing well uh because they're not in it
because they didn't get their chance
they didn't get their shock that's the
kind of the Woe Is mean covert
narcissist under the radar then you have
your communal narcissists so your
communal narcissist is the one who's out
there doing all the things
um they're going to the disaster relief
efforts they're volunteering and they're
showing everybody all these wonderful
things that they're doing on the outside
but in the on the inside in their homes
they're evil to those around them
um you know that that's that's a really
interesting thing because it always
perplexes me when you see these stories
come out and it's like these guys that
are very active in church and you know
they put on this really great front and
then you hear something terrible like
they're beating their kids right in the
scene and it's like okay I would never
think and I you know when I thought of
that I did think of like a few pastors
people I've heard whose parents you you
know their father was a pastor and I've
heard that several in in several
instances where their father was a
pastor their father was well known but
but was very abusive to them in their
homes and I'm not saying all pastors and
narcissists of course gotta give that
disclaimer but
um you know it's that same kind of um it
has that same type of tone to it the
person who is out there doing all these
wonderful things on the outside but on
the inside uh they're very evil to the
people around them or they're very evil
to the people they work closely with so
everyone who is um looking on the
outside may think oh my goodness this is
such a wonderful person to work with but
then the person they're working with is
like you don't know the half of it
um they're good at hiding it there's one
attached to the other like abusers you
could say are narcissists abusers I
think not necessary well
I would think so that they have
narcissistic traits would I say that
they're narcissists not necessarily I
mean they're such a a fine line when it
comes to actually calling someone a
narcissist versus calling someone an
abuser versus calling someone
self-absorbed because they're such
gradations to it you know what I'm
saying like it it's it you just have to
know the particular person you're you're
you're working with but I would think
that anyone who's abusing someone has
narcissistic traits for sure now are
they a full-blown narcissist would you
say this is more of a male dominated
disorder yeah definitely and I think
that's because most males
um are not taught to have empathy
you know crying is bad emotion is bad
um expressing emotion is bad men are
taught usually to just focus on their
achievements
and that's what narcissism is is
achievement oriented it's it's do doing
all these things to get a validation and
men are that's they're the prime target
for that depending on how they're raised
um I know that when I I remember my
father telling my brother don't cry you
know and him getting kind of uh taunted
if he cried you know so men because
they're raised in that type of way and
that's valued in society typically they
are brought up
um in this kind of self self this
grandiose self-absorbed
type of thinking that leads to
narcissism talking about empathy again
I'd like to bring up the definition
because I can now understand why a
narcissist would lack empathy but
probably be full of sympathy I'm reading
from uh psychemc.com and it says
empathy-ish is shown in how much
compassion and understanding we can give
to another sympathy is more of a feeling
of pity for another so empathy is our
ability to understand how someone feels
while sympathy excuse me sympathy is our
relief in not having the same problems
and you don't necessarily have to
um empathize with someone and have to
experience it in order to have empathy
correct
um just just being able to feel bad that
they're experiencing that is empathy but
you could have something like Whoa I'm
happy that that's not me right which is
their problem what's your class which is
your classic narcissist so uh a
narcissist wouldn't be able to empathize
with the feelings of others I mean it
takes us back to Second Timothy three
where the Lord says well I'll just read
the whole scriptures this know also that
in the last days perilous times shall
come for men shall be lovers of their
own selves Covetous boasters proud
blasphemers Disobedience appearance
unthankful Unholy without natural
affection truce Breakers false accusers
incontinent Fierce despisers of those
that are good traitors heady high-minded
lovers of pleasure more than lovers of
God having a form of godliness but the
but denying the power there are thereof
from such thou uh turn away it was
interesting how all all the all the
different types of a narcissists have
those characteristics in some shape or
form it's so opposite of the character
of God as well I mean you think about
what heaven's like right all of Heaven
is enlisted in what is going on down
here I mean they literally will will go
to Jesus and be like well send me down
there send me down them and they're also
interested to help and ease the
suffering of those that are down here
and you know the narcissist is like you
know now I don't care about you and yeah
it's just so opposite of a Heavenly
character trait yeah the complete the
complete opposite is all about self it's
all about what I can gain if I can't
gain anything out of it if I don't get
the validation and there's then I'm not
doing it what typically brings that on
like what what's the recipe if you would
for for you know maybe
Dynamics growing up I mean those things
got to come and stem from somewhere
right well usually it's and we talked
about this before attachment it depends
on how secure you were in childhood and
most narcissists I I don't know anyone
who's a narcissist who didn't come from
some sort of dramatic background either
they were spoiled to death there's these
Extremes in parenting they were either
heavily spoiled and given everything
they wanted yeah or never told no never
told no
or the other side of it they were
heavily abused and neglected emotionally
physically both and so um they grow they
grow up in an insecure environment that
it breeds anxious and avoiding traits
and disorganized attachment is a mix of
anxious and avoided traits and that's
what leads down the path of narcissism
then you have uh you know nature which
is society societal pressure societal
values and nowadays because narcissism
is kind of favored in society especially
in a capitalistic capitalistic Society
you know it's it's looked up upon it's
it's it's a good thing you fight for
what you want you you know you do
whatever you got to do to get ahead
survival of the fittest type of
mentality
um they don't see their behavior as an
issue because they're able to get what
they want you know it gets them far head
you know in life in their career so if
you're successful you'll be more likely
to pretty much like yeah dismiss some of
those character traits right anyone who
is a narcissist typically is not going
to say that they're a narcissist oh yeah
right they would never say because then
they'd have to be able to accept that
they're wrong and I really wonder like
some of those top positions and I'm not
going to call it any political names but
if you got to some of those top
positions are they all narcissists yeah
I mean I was kind of wondering that too
I mean can you I don't want to call
nobody out but I was just thinking about
all of them they're probably getting
trouble for that but can you actually
make it to those positions if you're the
nice guy well you know people like me
who are social workers we don't make a
whole lot of money for a reason because
you know what I'm saying you know those
types of careers where you're really
trying to help people they're not
favored right you know and if you look
at Jesus in his life
he he was poor he didn't have a he
didn't have a home to sleep in he didn't
have a place to lay his head you know so
you know if you just look at the life
and pieces and the character of Jesus
it's not about getting over on the other
person to get what you want it's about
I'm humbling yourself there's no
humility and narcissism so I think we
got through four out of five communal
malignant covert communal so we have the
classic cluster we have the malignant we
have the communal the communal I was
going to say also it's like in the
scripture that says um
and you'll give your body on the burning
stake but you'll have no love so you'll
do all these things on the outside but
on the inside it's a complete void there
really is no love there but on the
outside it looks as if
you throw your life in front of throw
yourself in front of a bus to to save
somebody but that's not really
um what's in your heart and that's why
it's so important that that's why the
that's why Jesus says um in Jeremiah
that the heart is deceitful and
desperately wicked who can understand it
because we could be doing all these
things on the outside that makes make us
look like we're just the the the the
best person in the world when we really
were Wicked
yeah you see that you see that in the
Bible Jesus is classifying the people in
in these groups and he's saying the
things that they did
and the one group is like yeah we did
all this stuff you know and he's like
yeah but I didn't know you yeah it's
like their motivation was no there it
was and I threw myself in the front of
the bus to make the newspapers not
because I cared about the person I was
saving I just wanted to have a good name
when I died right right so I'm thinking
how can we help someone make a
distinction because on the one hand it
can be said that hey that's what we're
supposed to do we're supposed to do
right regardless of how we feel on the
inside so how do you tell the difference
between
um narcissistic Tendencies versus I
don't feel good today but I know I'm a
Christian I know I'm supposed to
um do good to others well I feel like
someone with narcissistic traits is
going to be evident who it is they're
doing it for they'll make it verbally
they'll they'll verbally say you know is
it all about then or is it all about the
other other person I think that would
that would be the distinction and
someone who's narcissist they will
continually
um focus on self one of the praise right
for what they're doing okay right I I I
me me me so look for those key words you
know what I'm saying almost a bit like
Simon right when when
um you know he realized like what these
guys got the Holy Spirit look at what
they're able to do with this you know
like I want that like give me let me in
on that yeah you know and and it's like
if you just observe the the disciples
they were doing positive things good
things casting out demons and whatnot
and so you know if he wants it it's not
because he cares about you getting that
cast out of you it's the recognition
wants the recognition of that okay why
and it even reminds me of the disciples
and how they were on the outside in some
ways they had some narcissists to trade
suited Laura had to really undo um
because they in the background were
wanting to who's going to sit sit by the
king in heaven you know I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be sit sit by him no you're not
you know they were all about who was
going to be the next in heaven not
really about all the other things that
were really going on to help people to
heal and to work on themselves or see
themselves they were just worried about
toppling over each other sons of thunder
had to send their little mommy in there
to go you know try to get that position
right with the dad right you know it's
just it is interesting that was the day
the night that Jesus was crucified right
they're just positioning and and jocking
for that right no role right and even
Judas I mean I I think of Jude is more
as a covert and communal narcissist yeah
because he was all about show all about
making it clear that he was you know in
it to win it you know but behind the
scenes he was scheming uh to to set
Jesus up why are you spending that money
yes right right I always thought that
you know sometimes we portrayed Judas is
like you know he's this devious so it's
like look for the I I think he was so
good at hiding it he looked the part he
was the most successful I think he
wouldn't have you wouldn't have if you
were one of the disciples you wouldn't
have called him out as the guy that was
gonna and we know because we know the
story right but in that particular point
in time they didn't know they were all
looking around I said someone's going to
betray me they were like is it you is it
Meek you know and he was doing the same
thing is it me knowing that he would be
the one to betray him and eventually the
Lord said go and do it quickly you know
get on out of here and go do what you
got to do you know you read a verse in
second Timothy it ended with from such
turn away what does that mean exactly
how should we treat narcissists well see
that's the thing well I mean to some
degree you there's only so much you can
do because you can't avoid you know
coming in contact with people at work
and things of that sort however the big
thing about
um how we should treat narcissists is
boundaries okay boundaries but see the
problem is see I can tell I can tell you
how to set boundaries till you blew in
the face and they'll just knock it down
right but if you are not emotionally in
a good place you can't set boundaries
you know if you're if you if you don't
understand boundary setting yourself
um then you could easily draw
someone who's a narcissist to you see
narcissists one of the big things is
that they lack empathy the other big
thing is that they need Supply
and they can feel when you're the type
of person that they can get supplied
from
so if you don't if you kind of give in
to their their arrogance
and um you're not setting clear
boundaries with them then they know that
you're a Target
and so in order to not be a target for
someone who's narcissist we have to be
emotionally healed
and typically the type of person who
would draw someone like that to them has
their own background in and of itself
where they have a history of drawing
these types of toxic people to them yeah
I was going to say isn't this pretty
common in the you know the guy who's
probably that abuser type and then the
woman that's been abused and she gets
out of that relationship and what does
she find the next thing another guy
who's right just like that one right I
mean it's kind of classic and then if
you go into her industry a little bit
her father was abusive or her father was
an alcoholic I mean it always starts
from somewhere and so it's very hard to
set a boundary with someone when you
don't understand what boundaries are you
don't understand that you're not you're
not setting them or you're fearful or
sometimes we feel bad for the narcissist
we have sympathy for the narcissist but
they don't have any type of sympathy for
us like no that that whole um uh covert
narcissists who can come across as
depressed we feel really bad for them
Woe Is mean oh my goodness you didn't
get your chance in life you know we we
kind of feel bad for them and then they
reel it in you know so we kind of give
in to some of their behaviors and
instead of seeing those as signs and red
flags we just keep keep going forward so
uh I guess the flip side to that is the
narcissist who decides to uh accept
their narcissism how do they get help
well um it would take first of all hey
there's a difference between someone
who's narcissist and someone who has
narcissistic personality disorder
someone who's a narcissist probably
would never say that there are
narcissists and I'll explain why someone
who has narcissistic personality
disorder they have all the traits of a
narcissist this grandiose self-absorbed
entitled arrogance all about me lacks
empathy uh maybe mean-spirited uh
negative
um but if if they have narcissistic
personality disorder it is pervasive and
it affects their life in a negative way
so maybe someone who is an alcoholic
they have alcoholism as a result of
their narcissistic personality disorder
and they keep getting DUIs and they're
not able to drive they're not able to
get to work so it's kind of affecting
them socially in some sort of way it's
affecting their Community it's affecting
their life so that's why they would seek
help but someone who is a narcissist
it's working for them it's making them
successful
they think it works for them right and
if it's making them successful
they're not gonna acknowledge they don't
think it's a problem
wow I'm happy I'm not God right how do
you even judge someone like that right
so you would have to be at a place where
you're willing to to you know I mean
you'd have to be so broken from how this
is affecting your whole life in order to
want to acknowledge it and and even in
that even acknowledging it you're really
just kind of at that point just wanting
the pain to stop
you know so it would take a lot of work
to have to help someone to realize that
they need to be empathetic that's like
to making a um a nice person mean
do you think it leads to or kind of two
questions do you think that
many narcissists embody several of those
types that you mentioned and do you
think it leads to
other
disorders and what I mean by that is
this you take somebody like
David koresh
right
it's like this commune it is almost like
a Jim Jones kind of situation right it's
got all these people following him
clearly like demonstrating a lot of
these narcissistic traits probably as a
narcissist is it leading to other things
I mean
he's claiming like I'm the Messiah I
mean that's it's it's yeah it's
grandiose but it's like
it's pretty far out there you know I
mean is it I mean is he delusional is he
like well I mean Satan is your ultimate
narcissist and Satan doesn't stop he
doesn't have limits and so if this is
something that you if someone really is
a classic narcissist they don't have
limits it's not just gonna start stop
with just being being mean to people and
being a jerk I mean you know it's going
to continue to go go on and on sexual
addiction alcohol addiction drug
addiction
um all these things come with it because
there's a deep boy someone who's
narcissistic there's a deep void in a
hole in their heart
you know and they're they they're not
feeling it with the lord they're only
feeling it with self
but eventually that's going to be
self-destructive exactly what was the
name of that guy that was on social
media that everybody said Andrew yeah
you ever heard of this guy oh you never
heard it oh my you should look that up
I'm not classic exactly what we're
talking about we're talking about
narcissism on a level that is like
uh like unseen and then he learned how
to capitalize on that yeah to the point
where he then taught other people how to
be like that and then fueled by by
generating millions of dollars
crazy followers and then he basically
um got busted from raping women that was
what really brought him down yeah and
that and that's the thing like if you're
a classic narcissist you can make a
whole lot of money and be very
successful in the world's eyes because
that's what you're doing you're getting
over on people there's another girl this
was back in the not in the 90s uh Susan
you probably remember you probably
remember I don't know if you remember
but she I just learned about her but she
killed her husband he was a lawyer do
you remember that but she was a she was
a lady who killed her husband because he
no longer wanted to be with her because
they were having a lot of problems she
was having a lot of explosive behavior
he got tired of it he started seeing
someone else in his uh office he started
seeing the secretary and she exploded
she ended up eventually I mean they
ended up getting a divorce it was a
horrible custody battle and eventually
she uh killed him and his wife in their
bed she shot him in their bed this
happened in the 90s and she was on Oprah
and you can see her on Oprah and she's
still blaming now he's dead she in jail
and she's still blaming the whole thing
on him
the whole situation I mean classic
classic narcissist I mean that's more
malignant yeah she would curse him she
drove her car into his house
um she uh spray painted went into she
would she would break into his house all
the time and spray paint everything
break everything I mean just classic
just classic crazy uh narcissism wow
what do you do if you're in a
relationship like that I mean what if
your spouse or your you know what what
do you do in that situation right
because they sound really persistent
yeah well you gotta have a get first of
all you need to get if you don't have
Jesus you need to get them yeah uh
because um it's not gonna it's not just
this black and white thing but you're in
something bad it's less get out
um you gotta have a game plan because
this person is uh is evil
so you're gonna try to bring you down so
would you suggest that that person maybe
go and seek help outside of obviously
the knowledge of the spouse or right the
other person I would but it has to be so
under underground
um because the minute they find you out
right they're going to be consequences
for your for your behavior so you have
to do everything you have to be really
um intentional and um strategic without
what you do the hard I think do we think
that would be very difficult because if
you're in a situation where you're the
submissive person they're the dominant
person and you have your own emotional
you know baggage that's come to the
table like asking for help you know what
the other person's capable of right it's
a lot of fear there's a lot of fear yeah
very fearful this person has
intentionally
um isolated you
a classic narcissist has ISO will
isolate their Victim Because they are
fearful of the victim leaving them so
the The Narcissist even though they seem
bad bold and scary they're they're so
fearful and they're in a childlike fear
so when you see these relationships and
you guys have probably seen this happen
there's there's these two people they
get together you know and the one is
enamored by the other one he's the
greatest thing since sliced bread and
you bring them around your friends and
then that person is like gets mad at you
if you spend time with their friends and
doesn't ever want to meet your parents
and is always wanting to go away and get
away it just needs to be us that kind of
behavior yeah that's a that's a red flag
relationship like but see sometimes a
narcissist is very good at love bombing
okay um they're very Charming they can
be very Charming depending on what
narcissist you are encountering slows
bombing to the individual or to everyone
around well love bombing to the
individual but that everyone around them
sees them as a great person so nobody
the narcissist is not on the outward on
the outside does not look like a
narcissist everyone thinks they're great
it's but when you first meet them
they're doing all this love bombing so
they're reeling you in and so that in
and of itself is you're not seeing it as
isolation you know so it's easy if they
once they they don't really show those
characteristics until your hook line is
Sinker in the relationship
and so that's why you have to know you
can't get all caught up in the The Glitz
and Glam of the relationship you kind of
gotta if someone wants to spend all
their time with you and they're spending
uh 500 a month on flowers and taking you
out and dinners and you know I mean
unless you got money like that I mean I
know some people do make our money like
that but you know the average person
middle class yeah you know what I'm
saying uh that's what I'm speaking to
that's right you know they're not
um they're they're not spending that
type of money they're not wanting all
your time and see some Sometimes women
we get caught up in that you know
because we want validation in and of
ourselves so we're getting all this
validation all these all this
lovey-dovey from this person and they're
they're hooking us into this
relationship and once they've cornered
you then they isolate you
you know what we're really all along
they've been isolating you but it's been
it's been kind of covered with all this
love bombing so you're not seeing it as
that and then once the you really do see
the real side of then you're hooked into
this relationship you know you're tied
into them financially you may have kids
you may have a marriage and so it's hard
to unravel all that so the case where
it's it's early like you're not you're
not engaged yet but they're clearly
trying to isolate you from everybody
else that's not necessarily your classic
type of narcissist
um because they're not trying to cover
up anything that sounds as if that's
someone who's just a very jealous person
and you need to see the red flags and
you need to run
but not necessarily a narcissist so
they're they're more secretive
narcissist is very covert more uh a
narcissist is very overt you wouldn't
necessarily see all of those signs until
it is really bad
can you change I mean I I know God I
know God can change anybody but but is
do you ever see somebody who is a
classic hardcore narcissist
abandon ways and
turn turn around
it's rare I think I think I ain't never
seen it I'm not saying it ain't never
happened but yeah it's a difference like
I was saying earlier it's like you have
to it's like taking someone who is nice
and making them mean
you know it's doing the exact opposite
and so they they would have to in order
for you to acknowledge and get help for
your narcissism you'd have to be willing
to acknowledge all that emptiness and
all the emptiness that you're trying to
cover up is the reason why you're a
narcissist so you'd have to completely
unveil all that
I think it's like
um addiction scenarios right when you
want to be free from addiction they're
always telling you like pretty much the
first step is you have to recognize that
you need help and that's where well you
can't change what you don't acknowledge
right and they don't acknowledge that
they need help no and it's it's working
for them so it's working you know they
got money fancy cars nice homes let me
ask you about three four five million
followers example
um
what about the Apostle Paul
he had narcissistic traits yeah oh oh
Paul Peter never mind Paul is like
hardcore like go after the Christians I
mean and you wonder like well why is he
doing this he says he's like zealous for
the Lord you know he's it's supposedly
like a religious cause
but I mean he was the Pharisee getting
something out of it in that he's getting
the praise and recognition and he's kind
of climbing the Pharisee ladder and all
that I don't know I'm not saying he was
well on on the road oh but maybe that's
tough on the road Damascus he lost his
eyesight which affected his social and
occupational stress you know what I'm
saying so he had a situation that
happened that affected him being able to
be successful so I think that's at
whatever point he acknowledged okay I
gotta give you you they would have to be
they would have to lose all control yeah
see and that's what I'm getting at is
like is because you look at that
scenario and it's like you're like I've
never seen one channel like well is
there hope well I think there is hope I
don't know that Paul was that way I'm
not saying I'm classifying him that way
but he was definitely hugely one way and
then completely changed well if you hear
the voice of Jesus yeah might change you
real quick too and he you know and God
was able to use the the characteristics
that he had built into him you know very
he's very persistent and uh very boring
and things like that and he was able to
use it for a good cause so I don't know
I mean God can change anybody and I'm
not pleased to say that God can't change
a narcissist but God also works with our
will
so Victory is Divinity plus our will
equals Victory so if your will you'd
have to you your will would have to be
that you see that this is a problem and
you want help now that right but it's
it's very with narcissism it's there's a
scales and we're on the further end of
the speaker no doubt so you know but hey
does that mean that the Lord can't
change that absolutely I'm sure that
there's a gonna be at least one
narcissist who the Lord changed and they
in heaven they can live to tell the
story yeah I mean I don't know yeah but
a real dangerous position I could see is
if you blend narcissism with a religious
band yeah because then you become this
like well God's telling me this now and
that has happened in society I mean
drinking a Kool-Aid and all kind of
other different things
yeah there's that other guy the rlda uh
Church where he had like that whole it
was a pray love it's some documentary
that it just came out
it was crazy what was his name I don't
remember his name oh you really look it
up I mean That's a classic narcissist
right here so so these are all examples
of people that are extreme in that area
um that get a hold of a church or you
know whatever it's like that's kind of
the end result of of of that right yeah
but we can't the thing is with the
narcissist you know that the thing with
friendships or relationships is that
when you meet someone and they hurt you
you can say you don't have really hurt
my feelings you know I I didn't like the
way you said that you know and they
would be able to understand and come
into agreement with you and try to
change their behavior but you can't do
that with somebody who is a narcissist
well problems are probably a good thing
and in a relationship
um I think that you need some problem to
see how you guys deal with it you know
what I mean I think too many times if
people think that it's this this
glamorous relationship there's nothing
wrong we've never had an argument or
whatever and all of a sudden you get
married and that person like changes you
didn't know that they you didn't have
something that they saw that just brings
up cohabitation this is why people in
this day and age are called they're
they're living together before marriage
because they think that that's what you
need to do in order to really get to
know somebody but what we really need to
do instead it you know hooking up with
each other before marriage to try to see
someone's character and their flaws we
need to be reliant on Holy Spirit to
attack the person that is the best right
because he knows each and every car and
he can reveal things that are in our in
our heart that someone you know what I'm
saying that maybe we can't see maybe
we're blinded to but when we connect
ourselves with someone emotionally and
we get all tied up in that we're not
going to be able to see those
characteristics that further lead to
that destruction so it's good to ask the
parents it's good to ask your friends
they may see something that's that you
don't see but yeah bringing Jesus into
the relationship so you have this three
banded chord yeah I mean and that's
before you get into all all caught up
with somebody emotionally that's the key
we get all tied up into this love
bombing thing and you know Valentine's
Day and all this other all this other
Foolery that we're not able to see and
it's so easy to get Claudia up in that
in this in this Society because that's
what's glorified you know what is this
person doing for you not so much with
their what is their character you you
made this Con you made this uh comment
earlier about Satan being a narcissist
and if you look in the scripture there's
this huge contrast in in operation
between Satan and God so in Isaiah 14
this is the the chapter where we say
Satan has an eye problem right so I'm
going to re I'm going to read this it
says
um in chapter 14 started in 13 and says
for you have said in your heart I will
Ascend into heaven
I will exalt my throne above the stars
of God I will sit on the Mount of the
congregation on the furthest sides of
the north I will Ascend above the
heights of the clouds I will be like the
most time it's like up up up up like
right high as I can get right right now
contrast that
there is a contrast in scripture with
Christ again would be chapter two and
here it says let this mind be in you
this is the admonition to all of us
right
um which was also in Christ Jesus so
this is the way Jesus behaved and the
way he thought who being in the form of
gods was telling us who he was did not
consider it robbery to be equal with God
but made himself of no reputation taking
him down a notch all right taking on the
form of a bond servant Another We're
stepping down again yeah and coming in
the likeness of men
I mean we're going down right and being
found in appearance as a man he humbled
himself and became obedient to the point
of debt even the death of the Cross and
what is the result of that it's one of
those situations where it's like when
you're the one that's always going after
and trying to get what you want and
trying to push yourself up
right there's an equalization problem
that happens in God humbles you right
but when you let God humble you
and you submit to God this is what it
says therefore what did God do about
Jesus God is also highly exalted him and
given him the name which is above every
name that in the name of Jesus every
knee should bow right that's some pretty
significant recognition right of those
in heaven and those on the earth and
those under the Earth and that every
tongue should confess that Jesus is Lord
to the glory of God's father amen the
Bible says that he who humbles himself
will be exalted right
so maybe that exalts himself yeah we'll
be humbled right so where where is our
art like you were saying from Jeremiah
17 9 where are we coming from and
that can be difficult thing to recognize
we have to ask God to show us that's and
that is really what what the basis of
what I do is you know um you know you
can read you can look at several videos
and and read so many books on
narcissists you can you can learn about
narcissism but how do you stop from the
pattern of developing uh of getting into
these types of relationships these types
of toxic relationships how do you stop
from being toxic yourself we got to get
to what happened back in our early life
in our formative years because those
those formative years kind of shape how
we see the world how we see ourselves
how we see others how we see God you
know and if we're not acknowledging that
and we're not working with the Lord to
heal we got to go through a confession
stage there are some things that we did
in our early years in our early
childhood beliefs that we things that we
believe that were lies that affected us
now in adulthood we got to be willing to
look at those things and heal from those
things and ask God to give us new
patterns of behavior if if you don't
start that if you don't do that then
you'll always come under someone who is
completely grandiose and self-absorbed
and toxic or you will be that person
you'll be that manipulative toxic
self-absorbed uh person and that's uh
that's why I got we're at a day and age
where the Lord is separating the wheat
from the tears you know he wants us to
get to a place where we're really
afflicting our souls and coming to him
and saying if there's something in me I
need you to heal me because if it's not
healed if it's not work through it's
only going to grow
I like the way that scripture puts that
thought that you're voicing comes from
Psalm 139 verses 23 and 24 says search
me o God and know my heart try me try me
and know my anxieties and see if there
is any wicked way in me and Lead Me in
the way Everlasting right that's healing
right and we can't rely on the things of
this world you can't rely on the World
to tell you because the world gives the
impression that these types of things
are good it's okay to get what you want
and get over on someone else to get what
you want to get ahead you know the
antidote is humility yeah right and and
the more that you really focus on this
pattern of Jesus I like that you you
brought up you know the the the sort of
contrast
um when you study like world history and
you look at any of the other gods
they're always this Apex top yeah you
know and then you have this picture of
our God that came down and lower it's
just so contrary to what even human
Minds Can Dream above to be a God you
know like like all the fake things that
people have come up with over the over
the centuries
um they couldn't even think of a humble
story like the god that gave up heaven
to come down to suffer to die to like
take your penalty I mean that's that's
no in no other God story right and when
you talk about Jesus coming back and
humility he came back and he I mean he
took he he didn't even come back as a
person like he came back as a fetus like
as low as he could possibly get right is
how he came back he started from the
very beginning from conception I mean
that's you can't get any better than
that any more humble right in that like
he he went the exact extreme yeah as far
as um be it is as far as his Pathway to
heal the world yeah and all along the
way you know he comes and he's born into
this helpless situation a poor family
you know he grows up he recognizes his
mission at 12 but then still submits
himself yes to his parents to his
parents you know and and grows and and
supports the home before God is like
okay you know it's it's time now you're
you're 30 and you have a mission and
then what was the mission you know it's
like give of yourself give of yourself
give of yourself right right show them
what I'm like show them love right and
that's why it's so important for us to
go back to our formative years and heal
from any negative thinking because if
you were a child and you hated your
parents because they were abusive to you
or you were angry or you were a bully or
you were negative or maybe you hated
your teacher or you know whatever type
of negative these are types of behaviors
that we can have as children we're not
aloof to that just because we're young
you know that's where it starts we
developed this resentment in this
bitterness in childhood maybe your
parents didn't give you what you wanted
and you develop resentment towards them
you know maybe you're you're maybe
you're abused physically emotionally
sexually you know and you developed
hatred in your heart these are the types
of um patterns that start the way to
narcissistic behavior narcissistic
thinking grandiose thinking
self-absorbed thinking because you've
been so hurt now you're never going to
let anyone else hurt you again right so
then you hurt others you know
um so that's why it's important to go
it's so important to go back otherwise
you're not going to be able to know how
to stop getting in these relationships
it's you can have all the knowledge in
the world being able to put it into
practice it starts with the heart and
the motives of the heart we need to be
reborn like no matter what hand you were
dealt in life I mean yes some are
obviously clearly worse than others and
can do more physical and emotional and
every kind of damage you can think of
but I I truly believe that's why God's
like no I've given you an opportunity to
press the reset button and you know get
become a new creation right but I think
that in in Christian Society that is a
very cliche
there's a very cliche way of doing it
just cast all your cares on him just
pray it pray it and it's gone just pray
through it and it'll be no you actually
need to kind of ask for it do some like
specific things ask the Lord you know
what are the lies that I'm believing why
am I believing this way why am I
thinking this way why you need to go
through like an investigation period
right with the Lord we all have a book
everything that we think and we feel
everything that we have said is written
in a book right and God wants to walk us
through our books he wants to walk us
through those things that we've said
that have been hurtful painful Jesus was
never room it's not there's never an
excuse to be rude just because you woke
up on the right wrong side of the bed
I've never figured out which side of the
bed is the right side right and some is
left some is Right some is middle I
don't know but whatever bad decides your
bed you work work up on if there's no
excuse being mean to people unkind to
people uh just because someone's hurt
you doesn't give you a license to hurt
other people or hurt them back but we've
developed these types of ways of
thinking just because you're mad you
know everybody else you you want to make
everyone else mad and upset you know
we've developed these types of ways of
thinking and they come from unresolved
negative patterns that have been built
up over time and the Lord needs to go in
specifically not just pray through it
and just expect it to just go away yeah
but actually do some work with the Lord
for him to recreate you and re-patter
you give you new ways download new
thoughts the Lord has actually done that
for me he's actually downloaded new
thoughts I have prayed through something
and confessed something that I was
thinking ask and forgive me he told me
where it started where it came from and
he's actually given me new ways to think
that I never would have thought had I
not worked it through with him and
you're never going to be able to set
healthy patterns if you don't go back
into your into to where it started open
Pandora's box with Jesus you're not
doing it by yourself and ask him to
start pulling out that stuff that's
nasty so he can give you new patterns of
thinking download new patterns into your
mind where your parents weren't able to
build the bridge to see the Bible says
train up a child and the way that he
should go so if your parents didn't
train you up God the Holy Spirit has the
now re-pattered has to re-parent you
in ways that you were not parented when
you were young and that's that's how
he's able to heal a narcissist
you know one or two narcissists that
were narcissists that will be in heaven
that's how he's able to do it because he
is able to re-pattern them and re-parent
them because they had unmet needs and
their gaps in their voids and what we do
is we seek out everything else around us
to fill that need when we really need
the holy spirit amen
that was a great discussion and and I
think we covered four out of the five
what's the fifth kind of narcissist I
mean we we have a lot of information
there so the fifth narcissist is the
benign narcissist they are just on this
one they're done well okay
they're not me spirity but they just say
mean things but they don't realize that
it's mean-spirited like they may throw
you throw somebody under the bus
genuinely they have no yeah they don't
they just complete the aloof they don't
see how rude they're just rude and so
like oh my goodness I just bought a new
car you just drive around in that hoopty
for real you still driving that I just
bought a new car last week like you know
what I'm saying
um just not just completely insensitive
and dismissive even how people respond
to that they just they don't get it no
they will say if you could say well that
wasn't very nice and oh oh I'm sorry but
then the next day they'll just yeah
yeah they're sorry about how it made
them look but they're not really sorry
about their behavior got you so that is
interesting yes I've met a benign yeah
yeah yeah
describe it okay I'm sure we've all come
in contact with these various different
people over the years and didn't really
have the language to articulate it uh
you know so it's nice to have a
discussion like this and and kind of be
aware of those things and you know I'm
kind of going over a self-check making
sure like you know what do I do that do
I do that yeah I mean we can I mean I
don't think we're necessarily
narcissists but we could all have
selfish traits which is how you start in
the past narcissism yeah you know and we
need to be aware ask the Lord to make us
aware people use this term
self-awareness well I don't want to be
self-aware because myself can think that
myself cannot be that aware really
myself can think that I'm real good
right you know what happens that that
wasn't that bad but when you really go
deep and dive into it my mom motives are
right so we need to be cro we need to
allow the Lord to make us aware of these
attitudes and these behaviors these
things we say are non-verbal see I'm a
non-verbal person you know I no I'm a
verbal and I'm both okay my Express
himself you tell how I'm feeling you
know and I I need the Lord to make me
aware of those traits and those ways
that I come across um you know sometimes
smacking your teeth you know sometimes
we're just not aware of these little
things we can do and um walking away a
certain direction or how we you know how
it comes across to the other person and
only the Lord your self-awareness ain't
enough honey true that ain't gonna
especially if it's that's not gonna no
cultural culture someone else is right
that's not a that's not going to convict
you you need the Lord to make you aware
what are the traits What are the verbal
and non-verbal cues that I'm giving off
that can either
um
you know give a CR give off
self-absorbed traits or that can cause
me to be drawn to someone who is
self-absorbed yeah our actions speak
volumes about what we actually believe
in seven and and that's one of the
reasons why we actually started a
t-shirt
um Ministry that that really is wearing
your witness I mean you you you actually
are a witness all day whether you want
to be or not yeah and you know I think a
really good way to do that I mean how to
have an interesting Bible text on your
shirt I mean that in itself can can can
share with people but I'll tell you what
if you're being mean to people yeah and
wearing a Bible yeah
that's not a very good witness right so
you know what I mean like if you call
yourself a Christian act like a
Christian right you know have the
attitude of a Christian have the have
the humility and the ability to
um you know if somebody's mean to you
how can you speak a kind word back to
them yeah how do I think about that you
know if you look at our comments section
those aren't always very nice comments
but I hope that we're always responding
you know loving way like there's no
place for us to be mean yeah back or
right sarcastic or anything like that or
a Ministry we have a higher calling than
that so and I think also when it comes
to negative traits of behavior you know
not just being aware of how you come
across to people on the outside but how
you treat people in your home you know
how you treat people that's really
important what really matters actually
like you said yes that's your first
witness sometimes we can be so evil and
negative to our husbands our wives you
know people who we work with so we're
nice to everyone I read this book
fascinating book I had to read it for
one of my classes it was called
Dangerous calling I've never heard um
and it was written by a pastor for
pastors or people that work in Ministry
and it was kind of about this this kind
of thing not not entirely not about
narcissism necessarily but showing how
they as pastors
feel like they have to act a certain way
or behave a certain way
but at home it's like sometimes it's a
nightmare they're like struggling with
their spouse and their kids and it's
just it's Brokenness
and
um they're just fascinating to them to
read this man's story and how God had to
reshape him yeah and remake him and
break him well there you go there you go
somebody who's a narcissist to build him
back up and I don't I don't know maybe
he probably
the traits but I think what drove it was
people that are put in those kind of
positions where they're almost put up on
a pedestal like man yeah pastors come in
my house man I gotta clean can't have no
dust on the furniture at all right as if
they're not people you know as if they
don't know what it's like to experience
like my house is a mess and you know my
dishes aren't done sorry I just got home
from work or whatever right but putting
out that uh Persona so they they feel
like they can't talk to anybody they
feel like they can't relate to anybody
and so you know he had great suggestions
like if you're a pastor you should be in
a Bible study every week that you're not
leading
you know to for your own spiritual
health and development you should always
have a mentor like somebody you can go
to and talk to and bounce things off of
and really be mentoring somebody else
right you know yeah so there's a good
another suggestion hang around kids oh
there you go don't tell the truth all
kids are narcissists
but you know one of the key things that
you that you that what you said brought
to mind is validation that is one of the
things we I I didn't share is that
that's the ultimate thing that a
narcissist is looking for is validation
um everything that they're due they're
looking to be validated by everyone in
the world around them uh
everything that they do their work their
achievements they're looking and seeking
validation so that is doing that you're
putting yourself in a position by doing
that where you're not getting that
validation exactly they're not getting I
think for most people I mean normal
people you do a good job at work
somebody's gonna say something at some
point you know right hopefully more than
once like you know what you're doing a
good job I mean we all wanted we all
want that kind of thing we want to be
affirmed right that way yeah somehow
along the way but there's a balance
there's a balance if you're doing things
just to get that you're not doing them
because you want to do them you're only
doing them just so you can get that
validation that's a whole different now
we're going we're swinging across the
pendulum we have to be balanced
have you met a narcissist or somebody
who has a lot of these narcissistic
characteristics let us know in the
comments below please don't name any
names we're not here to call specific
people out that's not what this is about
but this show is to demonstrate that you
need to be aware of these things they
exist they may exist inside of each one
of us but we can get help through the
Lord Jesus we can look at his example
like we read about in Philippians
chapter two we can see the contrast
between what the enemy is like and what
Jesus is like and we can know that when
we come to Jesus there's healing so
don't forget to like this video share it
comment subscribe if this is your first
time here it's good to have you and
don't hesitate to check out our t-shirt
line like Scotty was talking about I'm
fumbling over my words but lightwear dot
shop and
um let's see what else patreon if you
want to support us we have patreon like
candy said it's a platform where you can
donate to us you can also do that
through our website uh actually we get a
little bit better rate through our
website so you might want to keep that
in mind it'll help your donation dollar
go further and this has been another
episode of LED live we thank you for
joining us thank you danitra for coming
yeah you have a website what's your
website
complementincomplete.com I also have a
women's retreat coming up in May
um we have all types of biblical
counseling programs we have free
resources so it's all types of goodies
uh plus the retreat coming up for women
of course and we help with chronic
organization anxiety depression toxic
relationships and how to heal from a
Biblical perspective so you can get
information for the conference and get a
hold of danitra I'm sure on her website
yeah so check it out and come and see us
next week take care bye
thank you
[Music]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]